President Trump is right now visiting
England I just said his name yeah there
was a time when you can mention
President and before you even said
anything else people just like alright
but have you got yeah but I'm on their
side
yeah I know you're on their side well
anyway our President Trump visiting
England any t he met today with Queen
Elizabeth did you know that yeah yeah
unlike President Obama this is the
interesting fact unlike President Obama
President Trump was not invited to stay
at Buckingham Palace yeah yeah when
asked why the Queen said we're worried
about our property value how about you I
am trying really hard I am trying to
follow the Democratic race for president
yeah I really am making an attempt I
think most of us are trying a little bit
yesterday a CNN hosted town halls with
Democratic presidential candidates
Eric's wall well Tim Ryan and Seth
Moulton yes all all three candidates
were asked the same question who the
hell are you who are you there was a
point in the debate where they didn't
know which one they were right all right
that was scary the president follow me
on this the President of the Philippines
claims that he was that he cured himself
of being gay the President of the
Philippines claims he cured himself of
being gay which seems unlikely but it
was later confirmed by his wife Steve
[Applause]